amid talk of the u.s heading toward a
possible recession friday's government
jobs report came as a stunning surprise
employers added almost 530 thousand jobs
in the month of july about double what
forecasters had predicted that brought
the unemployment rate down to 3.5
percent a 50-year low here to talk about
the state of the economy is yahoo
finance broadcast contributor kevin
cirilli kevin good morning
a massive report here what does it all
actually mean well michelle let's crunch
the numbers 528
000 jobs added to the u.s economy in the
month of july this smashed expectations
and brought the unemployment level to
3.5
this is a rate of the pre-pandemic level
and a an all-time historic record really
and that we haven't seen in decades but
it raises new questions for the federal
reserve which has been trying to combat
inflation and likely now will not change
its mind in terms of raising interest
rates remember that inflation rate is at
9.1 that's a rate we haven't seen since
1981. so the the job market was fueled
by growth in the leisure and hospitality
sector but there are other sectors that
still have not
returned to pre-pandemic levels i'm
thinking of restaurants in particular so
still some shaky ground in certain
sectors as this post-pandemic economy
shifts
and restructures into a new type of
economic outlook well kevin the fed does
remain the big question here right
because because this report was so
strong does that mean they dial back on
some of these increases which they were
slow to do
in the beginning or does it give them
even more incentive now to raise rates
further well jeff that's the big debate
here in washington because on the one
hand folks don't want to see fed chair
jay powell continue
to raise rates at a rate that would tip
the economy into a recession but they're
also looking at strong growth in wages
and they're trying to balance that with
high prices that consumers are paying at
the pump as well as at the supermarket
but if you look even further into other
sectors there's some more good news
particularly in the semiconductor chip
manufacturing we all remember those
supply chain woes many of which we are
still feeling as a result of shortages
in the tech sector
if you look specifically at high tech
manufacturing and those semiconductor
chips point nine percent increase in
that particular sector since the start
of the pandemic that's good news for a
lot of folks looking for jobs but we
also should note that this report did
not factor into the handful of headlines
that have come out in recent weeks in
the financial press about companies like
walmart amazon twitter that have said
that at minimum they are reassessing
their hiring outlook and there was a
recent conference board survey that was
just published a few weeks ago a
mid-year outlook by top c-suite
executives and 60 percent of them jeff
feel that the economy is still headed
toward a recession
we will wait and see kevin surely thank
you for your insight
thank you